Oh like Sameach hey you saved me a seat
it's for Elijah the Messiah you're no
Messiah huh what do you been talking to
my dad
that's my ninth Manischewitz I think
it's time to drain the old shofar you
guys doing sorry I'm late that rock on
my tomb was heavier than I thought
[Music]
are you ready to give you Easter sermon
yes but first let's pray and with our
eyes closed like really closed I was
turning wine into water yellow water no
one knows what I mean ooh tough crowd
are you guys Ephesians there just have
to do this story of the exodus
interesting well I was about to Exodus
to take this call
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry I had to step out for a hair where
were we
your Easter sermon of course you know
what I just gotta collect my thoughts
for one second I'll see you guys a
little bit Seder later back for dinner
but I cannot stay so I have to go bye
bye Jesus Christ what are you wearing
guess this might be my last supper with
you guys
[Music]
[Applause]